ladies and gentlemen time for a little
bit of positivity
i know something that i hate to do on
this show guys i see
positivity i go but it's time because
i focus a lot on the scummy side of this
industry
i feel like some of you guys know what i
don't like do you know what i
like even though i tell you guys don't
listen to all steve
don't listen to my advice i'm just
another idiot on youtube just like all
these gurus they're idiots too i'm just
another one of them right i'm just
another idiot i tell you guys not to
listen to me i know there are some of
you
who are dumb enough to do it anyway so
if you're going to listen to me you
might as well know what i think about a
few things because some of you have said
privately you reached out to me this is
some of the 13 year old bot
army you reach out to me and you say
stephen i want to be an entrepreneur
but i know that you don't believe in
that and i go whoa whoa whoa what do you
mean i don't believe in entrepreneurship
or they go stephen you know i i want to
invest in self-help i like self-help but
then you just seem like you're against
it and i'm like wait no i'm not against
it
and i realized one problem when you talk
about the negative a lot and you don't
spend as much time talking about the
positive people can
misconstrue you to be negative about
everything and so i wanted to be clear
that this industry has really perverted
a lot of really good
things that otherwise i'd be a really
big fan of and then it seems like maybe
to some of you i'm not a fan of i am
so we're gonna do a little talk little
coffeezilla talk i love
self-help coffeezilla confess that's
right boys we got a presentation in the
work
let's go expectation which could do a
lot of expectations versus
reality right guys a lot of people say
stephen you're so against self-help
reality i'm against predatory gurus who
promise quick
uh get rich quick solutions i actually
love self-help i don't know if you guys
know this i'm a big fan of self-help
it uh you know when i was a young lad it
helped me i mean i think it's a phase
you everyone goes through honestly
everyone goes through a self-help phase
you take some lessons
learn about improving yourself and you
apply them throughout your life but you
don't need to be like reading self-help
books forever i think you get like
the general key takeaways and you kind
of move on with your life
a lot of my life has been instructed by
learning things on my own
and that's the true ethos of self-help
is literally look at the
root self help you help yourself now
what's going
on is a perversion of that where it's
someone else
helps me that's the new thing someone
else tell me how to live my life that's
the guru mantra that's what they do they
go
watch me just copy me no no that's not
self-help so
i'm for self-help these guys who are
telling you to buy
all their stuff they know the secrets
they're against self-help i'm for you
learning the meta skill the most
important skill you can learn which is
how to learn if you can learn how to
learn on your own
you've cracked the code you can do
anything you want with your life
and if i had any overarching message it
would be to learn that i mean like i
said i'm really against
advice i think most of it's stupid but
if there was ever a good piece of advice
it's learn to learn
so one thing that i did as a kid was i
when i was
you know younger i taught myself to play
piano right i have a keyboard at my
house and that skill
has helped me throughout my life not
because i'm a professional piano player
but because learning how to learn piano
taught me
how to do well in college how to
do well with a youtube channel i learned
to learn
and here i'd like to recommend the book
the art of learning by josh waitskin
great book uh it's about this skill pick
it up guys i'm very pro
this what i'm not for is this treadmill
of like course course course course
course because i think it's
not actually teaching you the meta skill
of how to fish so
wanted to be clear about that make that
very clear i'm not
anti-self-help i'm very pros of help the
true kind of self-help
number two you're against investing
in yourself also not true
i know you guys might think oh stephen
he doesn't want me to spend any money no
it's just stupid money that i don't want
you to spend right it's
just spending your money in stupid ways
if you have like millions of dollars
none of this applies to you these guys
pay twelve
thousand dollars each to sit in that
chair i look over there i'm like man
they're crazy
let's say you're like most of us you
don't make a ton of money you need to
budget appropriately
well a guru would say spend your last a
thousand dollars with him grant cardone
literally said that
i got my last grand dude i got christmas
coming should you spend it on this
absolutely i'll tell you the same thing
what i'm for
is i'm pro investing anti-spending right
everybody knows they're good investments
they're bad investments
for the same price that you could get
one grant cardone thing
for the grant cardone special right you
can get a gym membership you can pay
rent that month
and maybe you can afford groceries all
for the same price now let me ask you
guys what sounds like a better deal
i'm just telling you guys with these
gurus a lot of these guys first of all a
lot of them just scam you out right by
not giving you what they promised but
even the ones
who are giving you something maybe they
are a businessman what is the
roi on spending a thousand dollars when
let's say you only have a thousand
dollars in your bank two thousand
dollars in your bank account so i guess
call me old-fashioned i'm like pro
frugality
anyway like let me just put another
reminder that this is all just dumb
advice right don't listen to any of this
but if you've got to listen to me at
least understand what i think
expectation three you're against
following your dreams oh boy did i get a
lot of emails this week after my debate
with all billy g
people like steven you're against people
following their dreams
and it's like no you idiot
i'm sorry but i've been trying to preach
this forever
i'm not against people following their
dreams i followed my own dream that
would be so stupid
i wanted to be a youtuber i went i got
my engineering degree and then i went
to become a youtuber and i'm doing the
youtuber thing i'm literally living my
dream
so i could not be more or less less
against people following their dream
what i am is pro statistics and reality
based decision making i'm not gonna be
your buddy
to lie to you and tell you you have a
good chance as an actor i'm not gonna
lie to you and tell you as an
entrepreneur you have a great chance
because the realities are what the
realities are
i'm also for not for like saying oh it
doesn't matter statistics don't matter
they do matter
which is why you have to make
evidence-based reality-based
decision-making
i still chose to become a youtuber even
knowing that it was
unlikely but i didn't delude myself into
thinking that it oh yeah i'm for sure
gonna make it that would be
stupid and it would produce bad results
on average by definition
so guys again if you're out there if
you're dumb enough to listen to me let
me say
i don't think you should not chase your
dream right
just understand what your dream entails
maybe get a safety net
it's not crazy to have a safety net
right that's why i finished my
engineering degree
before chasing my dream is i knew that
if the dream didn't work out
i could always fall back on something
right and so far i haven't had to fall
back on that but
you know with canceling being what it is
you know i might get canceled tomorrow
and in that case at least i'll have my
engineering degree to fall back on
um i picked up a lot of skills in the
meantime but that's my point guys i'm
not
anti dreams then finally
you're anti-rich people you can't
imagine how often i get this oh you're
just you're just a hater
on anybody who makes money you just want
everyone to be broke
false of course it's false i have all
sorts of people
that i look up to people who've changed
industries
you know uh like the meme or elon musk
say what you want about him he's
you know he's a little sketchy but he
really has revolutionized industries
sam walton same thing you can find
problems with the man but he
revolutionized
uh commerce with walmart right amazon
jeff bezos there are people
who are changing the world in a good way
and
at the same time enriching themselves so
what the reality is look how you make
your money is everything
some story i like to tell is that pablo
escobar was famous for trying to
launder his reputation and make it
better by uh donating a lot of money
right here's this you know drug kingpin
who is
trying to make himself a good name by
donating money now
i'm not going to say it's a bad thing
that pablo escobar donated money but the
point is
is that he's not a good person just
because he's rich being rich you know
it's not a good thing
it's not a bad thing it's all how you
made your money did you make it
by selling drugs did you make it by
changing the world positively did you
make it by selling a bunch of kids a get
rich quick scheme
like that is everything so when somebody
says to me oh i have more money than you
i'm cooler than you no you're not
you're and i'm not better than anyone
else that i make more money then it's
that that doesn't matter what matters is
how are you affecting the world i look
at people
who are running non-profits like the
khan academy right i look at people
like quincy larson who's running free
code camp they might not make as much
money
as a guru but in my opinion and i think
a lot of people would agree
they're doing way more to change the
world in a positive way
and that's what ultimately matters so
that's my list i think that's the end of
this presentation yep that's the end
uh and yeah i just wanted to get this
out there so
again don't listen to me i am uh just a
guy
but if you're gonna listen to me i don't
wanna hear
this stuff you know get messed up
because the truth is is that i'm not
anti-self-help i'm not anti-investing
i'm not anti-following your dreams and
i'm not anti-rich people
what i am is uh you know
pro-frugality pro-true self-help
i'm a pro making money the right way and
i'm pro statistics guys
so if you're down with that if you like
that kind of stuff consider following
the channel
because on this channel we're breaking
down some myths of the self-help
industry it's gone too far you know it
has that's why it's resonating with
people
and that's about it that's all i wanted
to share with you today i'll see you
next time
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick
trying to sell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee
[Music]